and ladies and gentlemen do we have
maybe unbreakable
roe v wade is gone yeah baby oh that is
beautiful that is a very good day for
this country there you go that is this
is this is this i want to read more i
just saw the first tweet about oh my
goodness the supreme court has voted to
overturn roe v wade
we hold that row and casey must be
overruled justice alito writes initial
majority draft circulated inside the
court
oh
my whoa this is nuts
this is incredible now you know here's
here's the funny thing
whenever whenever issues of left and
right comes up they say when is tim
going to defend abortion rights and i
just want to say one thing very clearly
when they come out and they're like the
left hasn't gone left and the right has
gone right
my entire life the republicans wanted to
ban abortion outright do you know what
republicans want to do today they've
gone so far right they want to ban
abortion
that hasn't changed the left used to be
in favor of some restrictions like a
compromise now they want it completely
unrestricted i'm not going to defend you
on that i want restrictions
so so here's here's where we are with
this is this is 8 32 p.m breaking the
supreme court has voted to strike down
the landmark roe v wade decision
this is nuts according to initial draft
majority opinion written by justice
samuel alito the draft opinion is a
full-throated unflinching repudiation of
the 1973 decision which guaranteed
federal constitutional protections of
abortion rights and a subsequent 1992
decision planned parenthood v casey that
largely maintained that right wow
we hold that rowan casey must be
overruled
he writes in the document labeled as the
opinion of the court it is time to heat
the constitution and return the issue of
abortion to the people's elected
representatives
i just want to i just want to point out
like
during the show
lydia will like pull up a story it's
like something's happening but usually
it's like oh we'll get to that and then
i saw this and i'm like trying to make
my point and i'm just like
objection so what you're saying that it
becomes a state issue yes yes yeah and
this is because they strike down roe v
wade everything that every subsequent uh
court hearing that was based on roe v
wade has now struck as well yeah we're
saying it'll be what in two months
planned okay
wow there's gonna be a lot of abortions
between now
this is this is earlier than we thought
i thought it was gonna come out in june
what's planned parenthood versus casey
this is incredible what that
what are you asking me 1992 court cases
planned parenthood vkc i'm not sure
simply put using the context clues it
was a an additional case in a similar
vein that reaffirmed the rights of
abortion federally wow i mean this is
extremely
good news i was not expecting to be this
happy at the end of my day today well
that's it i'm moving to canada
no this i mean this is incredible so
here's a quote from elite
row was egregiously wrong from the start
its reasoning was exceptionally weak and
the decision has had damaging
consequences and far from bringing about
a national settlement of the abortion
issue rowan casey of inflamed debate and
deepened division i'll just say this
this is there there is no
there there is no middle ground in the
issue of abortion there's there's none
there has been attempts at compromise
that's what it used to be safe legal and
rare that's where my family was
my i remember you know my family my dad
would say it's always wrong
but
you know sometimes there's issues where
we don't know if we have the right and
the government and stuff like that so
it's always a more libertarian approach
what we're seeing now from the left is
the argument that it's constitutionally
enshrined to terminate the life of a
baby which goes well beyond any position
i've ever held but i've always been in
the more libertarian position which is a
very difficult position because there's
serious moral challenges to it that i
don't have the answers to so i don't
have a strong moral position other than
it is a crazy thing that it really like
splits right down the middle like i feel
like if you just took a random subset of
5 000 americans 10 it would be right
like 50 50. but there's no it's it's
because on the the on the on the merits
of the argument there is no middle
there's there's no rational compromise
it's not possible yeah there's no
there's no compromise it's also
fascinating because when you consider
the fact that the supreme court case on
gay marriage was decided 10 years ago
and basically the entire population is
in favor a very large majority of the
population is now and you can lose your
job basically for saying you aren't then
you consider the fact that roe v wade
was decided what 50 years ago and 73 i
think yeah and so many people have
maintained their opposition to it
so the left never saw the cultural shift
that they wanted to with it uh thank god
for that this is a really incredible day
i mean there are millions and millions
of children who are not going to be
slaughtered because of this and so often
the right loses fails to take ground and
just allows the left to advance more
slowly
today we have experienced one of the
most incredible experiences that we
could as a movement because if we stand
for anything it has to be innocent life
i uh i remember when they they were i
remember them talking about when roe was
passed there was a growing approval of
abortion among the states and when this
happened they were like approval changed
like people stopped approving of it and
i honestly hope that this is the first
in a long series of steps that we take
to send these issues back to the states
i am very hard line on abortion but this
has always been a state's issue it
should have always belonged to the
states because this is not something
that was given to the federal government
in the constitution and the 10th
amendment is extremely explicit about
this anything that's not given to the
federal government should be left to the
states because the states are much more
in tune with what a smaller subset of
the population that live in that area
think and believe
so hold on hold on there a minute so i'm
i'm trying to tweet this out
but
this is an initial draft of the majority
opinion it seems extremely likely this
is what's going to happen but it was
leaked right so it is still early and
the fear is because it was leaked the
left will now launch some kind of that's
why they leaked it yeah it will not be
final until it's published like in the
next two months so it seems extremely
likely it will happen but what if the
left goes nuts what if they're going
what if yeah
hold on
sure my point is
what if by then
they change their vote
well don't don't they have a majority
because
i think you went down and said they it
was all is it five to four and what
happens if antifa goes and burns down a
bunch of cities and then all of a sudden
they're like oh no we we changed our
votes we that was a that was a draft we
we don't agree do you think that would
change their minds or would that set
them harder i think i actually i don't
know if you guys do you guys hear that i
think it's the lady from the the women's
march
she's shrieking you can hear the [ __ ]
i think i can hear her
roe v wade growing up roe v wade was
like the gold standard from my liberal
mother family it was always like you
know we got roe v wade we like that's
part of and that was only six years
before i was born but i guess that was
like such an intrinsic part of women's
rights this is according to my parents
generation i'm going to say the two
magic words you guys ready for the two
magic words does anybody know what those
magic words are going to be i don't know
if you would danny sheamus
happening we got a ronda called yeah
the the two words that tim poole likes
to bring up
um
touch of the c
second word w
can't win chicago white sox
that's pretty good
civil war
uh i actually do have a civil war union
i'm a dumb canadian
i don't know listen listen ladies and
gentlemen i don't know these rules you
need to hear this
stephen marsh we had on the show wrote a
book called the next civil war i think
that's what it's called right i believe
so yeah he wrote he wrote a follow-up
article saying that he believed abortion
had the potential to be a similar moral
catalyst now i i've been saying that as
well i want to read this for you this is
from dan diamond who is a washington
post reporter who said quote
he's quoting i think from an article he
says no draft decision in the modern
history of the court has been disclosed
publicly while a case was still pending
this is full-on sabotage of our federal
government by a political faction we
cannot survive if after hearing this
news if in two months they say due to
extenuating circumstances and extreme
political pressure we've changed our
position what do you think is going to
happen in this country well who leaked
it that's what i want to know so what is
this uh this opinion that alito issues
is the only issue to the other justices
the others it sounds like they all voted
for it and i'm totally having to move
back to canada so one of these one of
these they probably did in a closed room
i don't know the process but one of
these justices may or may not have
leaked this to one of their aids and
then that aide leaked it to the press or
that justice just leaked it to the press
either way this to me is
evidence that we need to get rid of all
of them and put new justices in nine new
supreme court justices if one of them is
corrupt that entire system is if they're
if one of those justices everything's
correct i mean yeah yeah i mean i mean
then that's nine we can't keep justice
opinion secret anymore what about if
it's going to be for the next guy
through a reality tv show very oh this
is this is crazy i'd watch it
everybody
it's like the apprentice
it's trump oh my gosh and you've got 35
candidates yeah and he's like you're too
far left get out you get a rose quite
frankly i i don't like i don't like the
decisions you've made in the past to be
honest i think i want to i want
president should not be putting people
in the court like that that is insane
that's how it's been there for 200 years
that's how it's worked i know but it's
just insane no no there's a confirmation
process yeah but it's like a it's like
around court
and it's like the senate gets to do it
it's not even that people don't even
have a say i wanna i wanna say a few
words my friends
so every winter
things calm down because people are
indoors
and they can't go out and do crazy
things
and every winter for the past 11 years
or 10 years as i've been covering
conflict winter comes around and
everyone says i guess it's all over the
riots and the protesting and everything
is done and i'm like dude it's snowing
outside okay
give it give it a few months and in the
summer you're gonna see it get crazy
again and then i was thinking about this
just uh recently because stephen marsh
wrote that article that abortion could
be it's he says abortion is a similar
moral issue to what slavery was for the
civil war and i've talked about that
and then i was like i wonder if a lot of
people are still thinking that there's
not going to be some escalation and then
i'm just like i genuinely believe
something will occur that will be an
unprecedented escalation
we have never looks like this a court is
what they're saying never has a draft
leak of a supreme court decision been
leaked in modern history it is
unprecedented
this is one of the most dramatic
escalations that there are supreme court
justices sure as ian mentions i don't
know if we get rid of all of them who
who have staff or someone leaked this to
the press
just undercutting our entire
system of governance
i'm really worried about what's going to
happen over the next two months but hey
man don't be surprised if you see
rioting and smashing a window just
disruption that'll be a better listen
yeah term limits lumber futures that's
the status quo now but look look look i
don't believe the left holds this as to
the same moral standard as the right
does to the right it's a very strong
moral issue to the left it's a tribal
issue that they talk about sometimes
but here's what i was thinking if the
ruling came out
i didn't think that there would be mass
rioting over this the reason was the
ruling is done what they would do is
they would start petitioning and being
like we've got to win and we've got to
get the courts we've got to win the
midterms
putting the the decision out two months
early
is perfect
for the people who would riot now i
genuinely believe we may see riots
because they want to influence yeah what
the vote actually is now excuse my
ignorance about the but does the
elections not factor into this because
the supreme court they do they do not
yeah it wouldn't right so the supreme
court set unless you need someone to die
or step down in order to change that yes
so this is the supreme court that
currently exists they're not elected
they're they're appointed and confirmed
the president says i want this person to
be a supreme court justice then uh the
senate then says yay or nay so typically
if the senate is controlled by party a
but the president is of party b you're
not gonna get it mm-hmm so you so you
usually need a presidency and a senate
of the same party or at least same
politics to make something like this
happen
this is
this is gonna get crazy yeah they should
have changed mayday they should be voted
in may 1st month of mary it should be a
vote the people should vote on supreme
court justices at this stage and there
should be 40 terms limits i disagree
because once you get that vote in there
you get the influence you get the
concern about possibly being re-elected
or whatever and if people vote and make
that decision they're like oh we regret
it we're going to recall them i feel
like there's so much more so um so much
more of a solid factor when you have the
president put them into place and then
they don't have to worry about a
re-election and because it is a lifetime
appointment they don't shift so much
with the tide as regular politics right
no no re-election you get four years and
you're out no real i don't want justice
as concerned about running for office
ever no no no it's it's good that we
have at least one branch in my opinion
that is for life
in canada in
yes i just explained it yeah but look
how canada is doing with it yeah not
great
um you know we putting people in in
charge of the country for life is like a
dictatorship it's crazy we have three
branches
so congress can impeach it justice
the president appoints senate confirms
and we've got the elected president
we've got the elected elected members of
congress they all have varying degrees
to their to their terms congress is two
years senate is six the presidency is
four that's a good thing senator needs
to have has that ever happened uh
surrendering justice getting impeached
uh was thomas the closest
did they try no no they didn't try to
impeach they're trying to feature no no
but they tried to prevent them from
being or they tried to prevent him from
being like accusing him of
untoward behavior indeed but the point
is some people are appointed for life
and i think it's a good thing because as
lydia pointed out they don't they don't
change the tides they stick to their
positions
there needs to be an anchor congress is
very quick every two years you get a who
knows what yeah although some people
never leave and then the senate is six
years which is a bit longer in the
presence he's four these different
amounts of time
allow there to be anchor positions so
the country doesn't just implode
instantly unfortunately it's not working
so well because the country looks like a
year it's a very slow implosion also it
took the federal reserve to come in and
take over the country and now abuse our
system and put these people in power for
life and then pay them off in the
background yeah there's been three
impeachments of justices the second one
in 1804 yeah they're like old like for
drunkenness and insanity though yeah
yeah
well you can't just be drunk and be a
you can't be a crazy drunk guy
that's i think there should be a reason
there needs to be one supreme court
justice who is a drummer aren't they
supposed to represent the nation all the
time he's he's the he's the tiebreaker
and he's drunk all the time just lit up
on me and crazy and crazy yeah they'll
be you give that up
moonshine
what do you think's gonna happen i don't
know i can't make a prediction here um i
very much hope that this is official
that it is overturned i know it appears
as if this was leaked early i'm not in
the business of making predictions in
this day and age but let's keep praying
let me tell you you know the problem is
with you seamus yeah you conservative
types what's the problem with this you
are satisfied by the by restriction on
abortion going to the states
i'm not satisfied by it no i'm not at
all no i think we need to go further no
yeah yeah i would make it illegal
nationwide if possible what if they
think what if they take a building out
to international waters and do it no
then i mean you do you prosecute them
the same way you would to somebody took
a butt out to international waters to
kill their already born child yeah let
me reframe it i was trying to be i was
trying to be oh sly
conservatives conservatives i'm bad at
that that's the conservative problem
yeah conservatives will very much be
satisfied by saying it's a states rights
issue whereas the left outrights like
ban like we want unfettered access
nationwide no matter what the left takes
the extreme position the right settles
with the compromise generally speaking
yeah that's usually how the right
operates it's very sad i think it is
starting to change more conservatives
are waking up to the fact that trying to
meet in the middle is not working for
them
yeah it's going to get crazy what's come
about with the whole texas the
the rule that they had with the six
weeks yeah like the suing and didn't it
now there's it's done all but what has
actually like happened uh other states
passed similarly yeah i didn't what
louisiana or something or yeah
mississippi i think
let me i'll tell you what's going to
happen
right now i assure you there are tons of
red states that are immediately drafting
outright bans knowing that in two months
they've won
i understand though if doctors do it
then they're going to go to prison a
bunch of women do it are they all going
to go to prison didn't uh what was it a
lot of people the doctors would go to
prison
i want to i want to i want to ask you
guys some questions
no yeah i've asked this question i've
asked this question um i think only in
the members only before but i have a
question
if
you saw someone
about to kill another person
you are legally allowed to protect the
life of others
so if an evil man
was
pinning down another man choking him
you could use lethal force against the
aggressor to save the life of the person
being harmed in in most circumstances
obviously if it's like there's a cop
who's you know attacking somebody
because they're fighting and you
intervene you might get in trouble but
if the cop was actually trying to kill
like just strangle the guy out maybe so
here's the point
if roe v wade is overturned and in red
states they pass laws outright saying an
unborn child is a life
and a doctor is about to perform an
abortion
what would happen if someone intervened
to protect the life of that child as per
the law of their state this is where i
think we get into civil war territory
yeah because now that we're it's getting
scary you can get like the bombing of
abortion clinics coming back that's
different well but i'm saying people
will be doing it under that guys where
they're saying vigilante justice
if there's no legal distinction between
saving the life of a child and an unborn
child because they are legally the same
thing and you have a doctor who's like i
am going to now perform the the incision
on the spine and someone says i will
stop you by any means necessary you
might end up with stories where the
courts say it was self-defense
to stop the killing of that child that's
what so
i think that's where we can get into
civil war territory i'm concerned about
miscarriages man like a six-month
pregnant woman falls down and hits her
stomach and the baby dies then what are
they going to charge her with
manslaughter because she didn't protect
and defend the baby's life she allowed
it into a dangerous situation i guess in
this sense it would be what the actual
procedure of
right well then you're going to see a
bunch of women falling over and landing
on their stomachs there are people yeah
i mean just like they did but well when
abortion was illegal and they had what
all the back alley
so they're abortions i'm sure some women
will find a way if they're so that's
true yeah so there were back alley
abortions all the supposed numbers of
women who died from back alley abortions
were literally completely fabricated
bernard nathanson who founded narol
admitted later on in his life after he
actually converted and became pro-life
because he saw the errors of his ways
that he was literally just making all of
it up um but yeah that's the answer to
that question right now there are people
who will be driving their car no i'll
tell you a story from my neighborhood
there was an old man driving his car and
he ran over a 14 year old girl
and when he went
he stopped put the car in reverse and
backed up not knowing what he hit and
crushed her head like a melon
he did not get charged
oh why because in order to charge
someone you need several criteria and an
accident like this with an old guy they
said he wasn't negligent
he was just an old guy driving and he
hit somebody panicked and killed her so
he didn't see the person before he hit
him they they uh he didn't see her he
was driving normally he was driving the
speed limit he was doing everything
right but he was just a bad driver
and my understanding is i don't think he
got i'm pretty sure he didn't get
charged he took his license away from
him there are a lot of people who
do things like you could be driving down
the you could be driving
and someone it could be pitch black on a
road and someone jumps in front of your
car and you hit them and you don't get
charged
and they'll be like you were driving you
should have seen him then a politician
didn't that happened to a politician
where he said he hit a deer
well i think he's getting charged yeah
well because he
i really doubt that's brutal i think in
the circumstance where you're driving
your car and you hit somebody and it was
a a real accident where the person
jumped out in front of you and it wasn't
you you were doing everything right you
might still get charged if it's a woman
who has a miscarriage and it goes to the
hospital i think it may happen but it'll
be extremely rare that the cops are
going to be like let's lock her up
that's terrifying yeah i mean there
you'd have to find me an example of that
actually happening i know a couple years
ago there was a story where a woman put
like a fully developed unborn child in a
dumpster and so they i think they were
investigating to see whether or not the
child like was born and then she put it
in the dumpster or if it was a
miscarriage but i don't know of any
examples of any of the states where
abortion is currently restricted or
illegal where women are pursued for
having miscarriages in fact in the ones
that we've seen the penalty only falls
upon the doctor thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there